you will hit what you aim at if you aim
at nothing you'll hit it every time
and once you aim you have to pull the
trigger you have to fire ready aim fire
you see if you went through college and
you did it in four years that was not an
accident if you graduated from high
school it was likely not an accident at
some point you laid out a plan and you
executed the plan to take the proper
classes meet the obligations to get that
degree high school college graduate
whatever it is if you went on vacation
and you made it back home it was not an
accident at some point you set a goal in
detail you pulled the trigger and you
did it intentionally if you got out of
debt you did it intentionally if you
lost weight you did it intentionally you
can put weight on unintentionally but
you can't take weight off
unintentionally unless you're ill so
these are intentional acts winning in
your family life in your marriage with
your kids
winning physically winning
intellectually winning in your career
winning financially winning in your
spiritual walk requires an intentional
act that causes friction you move
against something that was a was a a
stationary object and when you do that
it creates friction so you have to have
a clear path now some that some people
have more friction in some areas than
others we all are doing that but here as
we enter 2016 we're talking about what
it takes to win now I teach you all the
time about getting out of debt and I
talked to you about talked to you about
doing a budget never handle money
without having a written monthly budget
what do you think that is if it's not a
goal you write down I'm going to spend X
number of dollars on groceries you laid
out a grocery goal it's what that is
it's all it is it's a written goal and
that's why people win with money when
they do their budgets because they have
goals when you when you do goals that
are properly done you're able to execute
and win goals that are properly done
touch those areas write them down
physical intellectual
rear social financial family and
spiritual I'm not the first guy to teach
this as I told you SIG's Ziggler taught
it to my dad when I was looking at and
to me many years after and so did many
others have taught this concept for
goals to work they have to have five
elements or you ready to write these
down for your goals to work they have to
be five things number one they must be
specific goals I want to lose weight you
never will
I want to lose 30 pounds uh-huh one was
32 pounds now it's specific I want to
write a song I want to own my own
business I want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year it's a wish more money
is not specific I want to make eleven
thousand four hundred twenty two dollars
or more that's specific I want to make a
hundred and eleven thousand four hundred
twenty two dollars more that's specific
the second thing is goals must be
measurable you can't set a vague goal in
a cloud that's a dream and a wish it's
okay to start with a dream in a wish but
it needs to evolve into something that's
specific and it's measurable weight is
measurable heart rate is measurable
dollars are measurable profit number of
books you read is measurable completing
a degree field is measurable as specific
and it's measurable the third thing is
these goals that you have must be your
goals my wife wants me to lose weight
won't work
my mother wants me to be a dentist I
don't want to be your patient
my father always wanted me to be a
preacher I'm not going to your church
unless you're referring to your heavenly
father you need to have goals that come
boil up in your prayer time from your
discussions with God in side of your
heart inside of your chest
you need to feel these goals they need
to be your goals you need to have
emotional and spiritual ownership of
those goals it's mine my coach wants us
to win the championship you won't I will
do what it takes to win the championship
we are now in charge for the captain of
the ship when we take ownership but
you're not going to do things on someone
else's dime you have to live your life
your goals specific and measurable the
fourth thing is they have to have a time
limit
I want to lose 30 pounds when over the
next 10 years how many times do you want
to lose 30 pounds over 10 years oh you
too so oh yeah I want to yeah I want to
get out of that win I don't want to make
$100,000 win I want to have a net worth
of a million dollars win I want to write
a book when I want to complete my degree
win until you put a time limit on it
it's not real as soon as you put a time
limit on it instantly math starts
working you start breaking it down I
want to write a book when this year if
12 months how many chapters are they
going to be 15 you got average a chapter
and a quarter a month how many pages in
a chapter 60 so you got 290 pages in a
month that's three pages a day break it
down instantly and you'll be done in a
year it's how you eat an elephant a bite
at a time it's how you complete your
goals as a bite at a time you break it
down into small measurable parts and you
measure your progress along the way you
don't go oh it's December I was going to
write a book this year I forgot no you
lay out a dadgum game plan and you write
the book all through the 12 months
oh it's December I was going to lose
weight I forgot no you can't just make
it all up at the end that's in the term
paper where you can stay up all night
this is your life if they live it a step
at a time
I want to lose 30 pounds when
over the next 90 days I'll quickly help
me with the math would that be ten
pounds a month would that be two and a
half pounds a week and you increase your
water intake decrease your bread and
sweets intake and increase your sweat
your heart rate at least twenty to
thirty five minutes a day you will
likely lose two and a half pounds a week
especially if you've been sedentary
before that you'll drop two and that
pounds a week and if you're on two and
half pounds a week and you do that for
three months that's thirty pounds two
and a half pounds a week is four weeks
in a month is ten pounds
follow me this is how it works I'll make
$100,000 a year great per year this year
right okay that's eighty three hundred
bucks a month
yeah that's $2,100 a week that's how you
get there by the way if you want
multiply that times two you get two
hundred thousand this is simple math if
sixth-grade they teach it to us there
and we need to do more of it and there's
not an app for it it's called your life
you need there's not a your life app you
need to live your life it can't happen
on your smartphone it's not automatic
you have to engage in the friction to
cause these things to happen so those
that work must be specific they must be
measurable they must be your goals and
they must have a time limit the last one
is the magic they have to be this most
important one of all of them in writing
they have to be written down you don't
write them down they're not going to
happen the Bible says in Habakkuk right
the vision and make it plain so write it
down don't just go home when we go
hundred thousand no write it down and
break it down write it down and break it
down write it down and break it down
write it down something happens when you
write it down if you write it down and
show it to other people now it's game on
baby it's game on because you put
yourself out there now you said I'm
going to do this and now other people
are going to hold you accountable just
the embarrassment if you don't we'll
hold you accountable
I'm gonna lose weight you keep that as
your secret little secret it'll never
happen you write it down and break it
down and write down the steps you're
going to take the caused that to happen
and show that to someone and you'll go
do it you won't get out of debt that's
how you get out of debt right there it's
called the debt snowball you write it
down that's how you win with goals
there's your kickoff for 2016 this is
good stuff you don't get this free
anywhere else this is the Dave Ramsey
show you know why most people don't win
they don't bother you have to bother if
to be intentional never again as
American Express going to call my house
and ask my wife why she would stay with
a man that won't pay his bills